[Musique]
télé réalité1 ouais ça me verrais
pendant en fait l'idée ce que j'aimerais
bien placé il voit là on est tous en
tout pendant 20 ans qu'est ce qui
m'énerve en ce moment et rien que
m'énerve plus en ce moment parce que je
passe des soirées super quine ou
décontractées tous les soirs sur la fête
avec
amis du csa d'ailleurs que je fasse
gaffe à mon poids parce qu'ils sont une
sacrée descente et après on fait des
partouzes donc tout ça ça me calme en
fait et tout ce qui m'énerve ça
disparaît grâce au cssa est alors
aptitude à faire la fête merci c'est
simple ah bah non je ne suis pas sur
instagram je peux envie de me faire
chopper pour harcèlement mois